you were standing there and I was like I
was like I don't know good bad wine
waiter hands like IMDB I'm like a WWF
manager or something there is that kind
of great though you can just walk the
convention floor and then there's like
the few people that'll be like oh my god
yeah no III pressure my anonymity you
know some people like Gwen or Peter can
never escape that you know because of
their appearance but I just grown my
hair and I'm anonymous again it's right
my god I love it that is so funny
I didn't do it to you I did it for the
Seven Kingdoms how's your time like
how's it going here great I love it I
love the fans and the enthusiasm and the
effort they put in - it's a different
generation I wouldn't go into this
trouble you know mm-hmm have you had the
chance to you know soak it in have you
walked the floor at all no no I'd like
to but not on my own I'd be too scared
on my own I think so yeah one person
will be like oh my god yeah yeah shame
shame
I think we're going down there in a
minute you're gonna kill us we're gonna
tear us limb from limb limb from limb
yeah it's been that's been chaotic in
here